So here we have our circular earth,
which I'm trying to represent in 3 dimensions
by showing the equator, and somewhere here,
we have Syene, and somewhere here--
and I'm going to exaggerate this distance
to make the drawing easier--we have Alexandria.
Now to begin solving this problem, Eratosthenes did what
physicists often do when they're tackling
a really difficult problem.
He made an assumption.
And now the assumption that he made was that
the sun was so far away, way, way, way
off the screen, that when the sun's rays arrive at the earth,
they're coming more or less parallel
no matter where on the earth you are.
Now these lines are parallel--
we assume they'll never touch--
and why was this a safe assumption to make?
Well, let's take a look.
Let's draw a little play version of the sun over here,
and now this is totally separate from what's going on over here,
and let's look at the sun's rays.
Here they are, radiating outwards from the center
from the sun, and you can tell that
they're certainly not parallel.
What happens is we get really, really,
really far away from the sun like way out here,
where we've got more rays like this.
We can start to see that if we're really far away
from the sun--maybe if our earth is over here--
well, in this neighborhood, the rays
do look more or less parallel.
They're not exactly parallel--they seem
to be diverging a little bit--but
maybe it's good enough for our purposes.
We'll examine this more in the homework.
Okay.  So we have our rays arriving parallel
at Syene and Alexandria.  Now what?
Now how am I supposed to figure out the
circumference of the earth based on some
parallel rays and the observation
that they're striking vertically here at Syene.
Well, before we jump into the calculation of the
circumference, let's try and understand what's
going on here first.
Well, we've already talked about a person standing
here in Syene--their shadow would be directly below them,
because the sun's rays are striking vertically.
Here in Alexandria,
a person would have a tiny little shadow,
and you can see that the angle from the head
of the shadow to the head of the person--
this line actually follows the sun's ray.
We'll be using that more later, but, for now, let's think.
If this person started walking north, closer to the
pole up here, what would happen to his shadow?
Would his shadow lengthen as he walked north, or would it get smaller?